my name is kill today I present you
first results from my collaboration with
DBS and posit I wouldn't be here today
if not for hanis and Tom and Davis
Hedley Andrew and Kevin and thank you
for joining me in this presentation so
DB we have heard in case you missed the
previous talk is the new high
performance database that works in our
in Python in Java JavaScript rust Swift
Scala I don't know everywhere and it
integrates with
arrow deeper this is example code using
the texi data that Hannah's just shown
it computes the median tip
percentage by Passenger cone in the this
data cap rides in New York City in 2019
1.7 GB compressed more if you uncompress
this and you can load this into memory
you can use deer to compute this but
have you actually tried to do things
with such a large data set in deep plier
I feel uneasy I'm not very patient this
takes 8 seconds on my machine and
spoiler alert with duck player is going
to be much faster but before we get to
the how let me start with why so I get a
lot of joy of writing and reading de
player code even if you're not familiar
with the syntax you can read from top to
bottom you can see what each individual
step is doing and you can execute parts
of the pipeline to inspect intermediate
results now this is a SQL version of the
same
query the order of operations is mixed
up and to run a simplified version of
this thing for I don't know debugging
you would have to carefully edit it so I
find for incremental building and
debugging deer is easier is better now a
feature metrix could look like this we
have deepl which is nice but slower we
have dctb which uses SQL but it's super
fast H spent like 20 minutes on
explaining why multi-threading native
code and the queries it sees the queries
and it optimizes them as a whole end to
end chooses the best way to compute the
desired result maybe the most important
thing hanis and his team talented
database Specialists with Decades of
experience and this is their day job
this is what they do they in they out
making duct DB faster and faster and
faster and ever faster so can we have
the icing and the cake can we have fast
D plier yes this has worked before with
the blier we can take D player code
conver it into SQL run it on the
database get it back as a data frame
continue operating in
R and there are other such systems such
as data table and DT player there is
Arrow there is collapse there may be
more that are implementing the Deep
syntax what is wrong here well we
inherit too many features from the
underlying
database dctb can read Pary this is
great dbpl can also read par key dctb
works with data sets larger than memory
perfect DB player works for data is
larger than memory but when we get the
data from DB player it's not a data
frame we have to collect it transform it
to a data frame we don't support all the
r functions we don't support all the r
data
types and for some functions even the
implementation is or the semantics are a
little different bottom line chances are
your deer code if you take it
and try to run this with theb plier will
not work work out of the box now unlike
duck player duck player is designed as a
full drop in replacement for deer data
frame in data frame out support for all
data types all our functions I mean yes
we try to do things in dctb if we can't
we just offload to D plier and handle it
there without breaking your code
my goal is to make all of your deer code
work with duck plier and make more and
more of your code work faster so that
you can focus on what matters to you and
Achieve better results in less time
development time and computation time
and now this is me working on Deck plier
so test green everything passes we need
a new feature maybe we go to hanis and
ask them to build something sometimes
it's the other way around duck DB
changes Behavior it challenges my
expectations but it's a lot of fun
iterating between correctness
performance and
completeness so working on Duck pler is
test First Development except the tests
already exist we don't need to write
them we have three and a half thousand
test cases in the deer package and we
can adapt them to run against duck
plier and we have 4,000 packages on
Crown that use deer directly or
indirectly we can create a modified
version of
deer that uses duck
plier and see what happens with those
packages so the combination here helps
us find the occasional bug and also
guide our development efforts this is
great
now if you've been in Davis's talk. by
is the new kit on the blog for grouped
operations group I we do not
support this is laziness this is because
um we want you to use the new syntax and
frankly few things can go wrong this way
now what happens if you compare an
integer with the string what happens
when you compare an integer with a
factor on what
day of week does does the week start and
our and duct have different opinions
here on and and on many many other
questions this is why we support only a
small subset of of the functions right
now this is more more opt in than opt
out we know how to handle those all all
this is now takes us time to implement
basically the rest of that now
one more difference is row order so if
you think about a data frame you sort a
data frame by a specific column in
Deer and if there are ties if there are
multiple rows with with the same value
the or original order of rows will be
preserved with d plier and DB just
doesn't care because DB cares about
performance they might just Shuffle
around your rows this is why we have two
modes of operation a slower mode that
will maintain the original row order and
fast mode that will do whatever dctb is
doing here and we'll see which one will
uh be most useful in the end now
speaking about performance I did not
dare to make a live demo but I'm showing
you how this looks like in the r Studio
IDE now this starts in a clean R session
I'm attaching the Deep fer I'm attaching
the duck PL package and I'm using
conflicted here to reduce the noise and
to be very specific about the functions
I use if you're not familiar with that I
highly recommend this for your
scripts this is the same query I had in
the beginning the taxi data ingestion
preparation summary and I'm running this
in three statements and these take no
time push push push they're done
immediately and this is because nothing
has been actually computed here you see
in the bottom the
results just do not know the number of
rows just yet these are data frames lazy
data frames but these
are proxies and they need to be computed
in order to be available as full data
frames yet they have a class the class
is data frame and the subass they have
column names they have column types just
not the data yet I can use duck DB
internals to see what will happen when
the query is actually executed so this
is a lot of output and it reads from
bottom to top so we start at the bottom
with
ingesting the park file and we read only
the columns that we need and only the
rows that we
need further along the way there is this
transformation computation of
percentages there is the grouping
operation and there is the ordering of
the output and all of this from start to
finish runs as a single duct DB
operation data mentions fast we'll see
so running this touching a column
quering getting the value of a column
actually triggers the computation again
this output is huge in the middle you
see the vector 9 87 and so forth that's
the regular R Vector that comes back
from this operation at the top
we see the recipe that's what dctb is
using to compute the result and the
structure of the output this can be
turned off I feel for now it's useful to
have this on and because I used system
time in the code I see it took 1.8
seconds to run and it in the user column
5 Seconds of computation time meaning
more than one core more than one
processor was involved multi- threading
now we're doing this a second time or we
are accessing the full data frame this
is instantaneous because once we have
computed it we do not need to do this
again of course if we compare this with
the more traditional deoy workflow like
loading the data and then doing the
computation the texi data variable
that's the first I get the number of
rows this also triggers the computation
and this is now all the columns and it
takes 4 seconds and doing the whole
analysis took two so well I think um
that's already an improvement
the arrow the the the refresh thing in
the environment pane now actually is
useful clicking on it shows for the data
sets that we have
touched how many rows there are and we
see taxi data prep that was the
preparation has not even been
materialized yet we don't need this
because the result has been computed
from end to end with that DP now this
has been recorded for the very recent
and as in nightly built version of their
Studio ID I'm not sure if this is in the
release yet maybe you need manual
refresh only in your version of the IDE
or of the posit
workbench so we run this with a few
other queries the query I showed was
fastest in deep all the variants with
more groups or that included join with a
dimension table take about 20 seconds or
more in deep all of this runs in less
than 2 seconds in Duck PL in order of
magnitude just like that I really like
this particular result
so completeness one thing we do not
support yet is custom R functions if we
had a code like this and this might take
a second to digest so instead of
computing in line we would Implement a
compute PCT function the compu the
percentage this will not be handled by
duct DB still it will work so what's
going to happen here mutate from Duck
plier the function we see a compute PCT
I don't know what that is I send it to
deer and deer will just do it it will
call compute
PCT query
the the value of the column and by
querying the column it will actually
start computation of the
filter which still will be in Duck DB
duck
plier so this will work a bit slower but
still you don't have to
change your code at all I
hope now there is work to do we would
like to support more data frames
especially maybe spatial data frames
would be useful Hannis mentioned nested
and pack columns actually they do work
in Deb they just don't work in Duck
player yet more R functions more data
types ideally all R functions all data
type we see if we can get to
there we have a good idea why we're
doing this we have a good idea how to do
this now we only need to know watch and
for this we will need your help you can
install this today it is on Crown the
binaries have been
built all this will do is get you an
updated version of deer and duct DB in
case you need it it won't otherwise
change your system and there are two
basic ways to use this first as du play
DF you write this as the first uh step
in your pipes and this will run the deer
steps in Duck plier but you have to do
this with every pipe you have if you're
courageous methods override will send
everything to duck plier and don't worry
this will reset when you restart the r
session and there's also a function to
turn it
off this is the
GitHub I would love to hear if this
works for your
code file an issue drop me a line
we have a presence at the in the lobby
and I'd be happy to take questions here
thank
you thank you we have five minutes until
the next talk so we have plenty of time
for questions so please do submit them
on slido if you have them um I have a
question uh is the goal to one day
support 100% compatibility with dly
including things like groupby including
things like group group
bu I wouldn't place bets on group bu but
for the other parts of the question so
basically yes if you find that something
that works in DLI does not work in Duck
plier this is bug because we really
strive to near full compatibility I know
this is elusive because this the slope
gets gets gets very very steep at the
end but I don't want to put a figure on
it
it just just we will look at everything
that that you sent our way sounds good
mhm uh do list columns in data frames
work with duck plier come back next
month nice quick answer I like it um is
there an advantage using duck plier
alone versus starting with a tibble
converting that tibble to an arrow table
and piping it to Arrow to duck DB
so you can do that one thing I forgot to
mention indeed that you do not have to
start with a parket file so Hannah said
this too you can start with a data frame
I just didn't have the data in memory
just yet in My Demo which is why I got
this straight from the Parky and this
also give gave the nice speed up so you
can start with data frames you can start
with arrow you can start with CSV with
Parky with anything that dctp can ingest
and we have a function that that allows
you to to
read um those files
that's great um what is on the road map
for duck plier that you are most excited
about definitely nested and packed
columns so and this is this is the lwh
Hang fruit I think
and
well yeah I'd say Okay M all right um I
think that's all the questions I have so
let's uh give a hand again to K for his
[Applause]
talk